when we started this topic of mechanics
right where we began was by getting
things into context and the very first
new idea at least for those of us who
don't study physics is we looked at the
three laws of motion that we earn to
Newton right what were they we came up
with short succinct summaries even down
to like one or two words for each one
what was the first law of motion about
inertia
very good which means stuff wants to
keep doing whatever it's doing whether
that's be at rest or whether it's moving
in uniform straight-line motion just
just leave me alone let me keep doing it
that was the first law second law was
that short Sun report it was the fact
that inertia like not all objects were
created equal right some things have
more and some things have less depending
on how much mass they have right so we
talked about the inertial mass how much
stuff there is and how resistant it is
to being changed right and then we had
one last load remember it was what was
about reaction that's good okay so every
force has its equal opposite right we
get the idea that's what we began now I
want you to remember that in extension 1
right
we considered further than to unit we
considered two special instances of
motion and we had a look at all the
different equations that went in there
right in under extension one what were
the two particular clients of motion
that we looked at remember simple huh
buddy
and projectile excellent now what we had
a look at these what we did was we took
some simplified models okay we thought
about only particular kinds of aspects
of the situation you know maybe that it
oscillates mainly that there's two
dimensions and we take gravity into
account right and then we were able to
relate them to very very simple
functions that we're very familiar with
right so super harmonic motion it went
to the trig functions
okay wave functions and for projectiles
of course the equation the shape that we
got out of that was that prowler okay
and we did all kinds of weird wonderful
things there but here was the problem
right or was a problem that we chose to
ignore you can only consider these
situations with these nice neat
equations relatively anyway if you
simplify and if you take out of the
situation
take out snow somebody that's very
obvious and very sort of familiar to us
namely that you know simple harmonic
motion right things do not move like
this constantly forever right unless
something's constantly you know
supplying energy and force and things
like this right it's not simply up-down
okay
in fact even though we try to do some
measurements outside or lycopenes right
experience tells us that when things are
going up right versus going down it's
not exactly symmetrical what is that
common every day in florid that we're
missing resistance good so
this is a big idea okay and taking into
account it's sort of well it introduces
a lot of interesting maths okay as we're
going to see so what is resistance let
me start by giving you a bit of a
definition okay so when we move to our
medium now what's the medium medium
medium is like stuff like if you're
moving through a space and this stuff in
the space and the stuff might be as you
were just describing it might be yeah it
might be what other kind of stuff to
remove through water what else mud
oil whatever you want okay so long as
this stuff this etc okay what's
happening is because there is inertia in
here right because inertia does not just
act on like big stuff like us but the
meaning itself is made up of stuff that
has inertia right the air around us and
the water that you're is around us if
we're in a pool or the beach was like
that just like everything else in the
universe
it has inertia it doesn't want to move
out of the way and has to move by the
way if we're going to take up that space
instead right so when we move through a
medium the medium resists okay and
evidently the more mass the medium has
according to the second law the more it
will resist but which is why of course
it's harder to move through water
because water has more was denser which
is why it has more mass than in a sort
of an equivalent space of air right so
when we move through a medium the media
resists we call this in general we call
this resistance when it comes to air has
a special name it's called drag it's not
any important but sometimes you'll see
it okay so you measure a medium the
medium resists because of inertia it
resists sort of in proportion to initial
mass but also because of the third law
right when you want to force this acting
is going to be a force
in the equal and opposite direction
right so it's not just that the medium
resists in proportion to you know how
much mass it possesses right but it will
also resist more based on what are the
kind of factor think about it so so
we're moving through a medium here I go
right now obviously the medium around me
if it has more inertial mass it will
resist me more but there's something
else that will make the medium resist me
more that has nothing to do with the
mass of the medium what else is going to
change the amount of resistance it's how
fast I'm going right which is why when
you're in you know in a car it's going
really fast you feel the resistors right
whereas if you run a slow as I D if I
have a feel any resistance at all right
so you've got the mass to worry about
and that's what we get from the first
and second laws but the resistance now
you gonna be careful here I'm gonna
introduce the idea of proportionality in
a little more formal way when we have an
example okay but proportionality it's
hard to use that language here without
saying something that might be
inaccurate in some situations so all I'm
gonna say is the resistance increases
with grade up velocity
okay because of the third law the more
velocity it has the more force that's
exciting in a certain direction
the medium is going to exert back right
and it's going to exert that more if
there's greater velocity does that make
sense
okay good now one more piece of language
okay this idea of resistance of the
medium sort of pushing back okay that is
force language that's force language so
this is where the force opposes the
direction of motion okay so me I mean
from your perspective I'm moving from
right to left
okay so there's going to be a force
acting from left to right right but
there's another word it's important it
seems very similar okay but it's
different it's sort of weird on top of
resistance we have this idea of
retardation resistance right which is a
force work it causes it causes
retardation which is an acceleration
word okay so this is where acceleration
opposes motion
okay so here's a cause and here is its
effect does that make sense you're
equally see both I mean in in our terms
and the questions Meghan are you looking
at this is always gonna cause this okay
but you need to be able to distinguish
between a word because the words will
both come up